bernardino a inspiré de nouveaux propos
incendiaires à donald trump le meneur
dans la course à l'investiture
républicaine
j'en parle avec tron notre correspondant
à washington
christian alors encore une fois dont un
choc attirent l'attention avec des
déclarations radicales là pour le mois
vous savez ces lignes c'est son rôle à
dont le charme d'attirer l'attention il
est très bon en général il sait très
bien qu'il va provoquer presque à toutes
les fois encore une fois vous l'avais
dit dans votre texte
on a appris aujourd'hui c'était confirmé
par le fbi ya que les deux tueurs de san
bernardino avait été radicalisé à
l'extérieur des états unis donc dans
l'ensemble a été très rapide sur la
gâchette et il a pris la balle au bond
et l'a écrit un communiqué cet
après-midi disant qu'on devait empêcher
d'entrer tous les musulmans d'entrée aux
états unis jusqu'à ce que le congrès
trouve une solution alors les médias
sociaux se sont enflammés il était
critiqué de toutes parts on l'a traité
de nazi de fascistes de démagogues
même ses adversaires républicains l'ont
dénoncé et il trouve qu'il fait le jeu
des terroristes qui tentent de
convaincre en ce moment le monde entier
que les américains sont en guerre contre
l'islam
ce n'est pas le cas c'est pourquoi le
président obama le répète à chaque
reprise
mais dans notre homme n'a pu s'empêcher
encore une fois en soirée céline de dire
ce qu'il avait écrit un peu plus tôt cet
après midi
christian il est le meneur de la course
à l'investiture républicaine son avance
augmente même alors c'est difficile de
l'ignorer
on ne peut pas l'ignorer écouter les
seize points d'avancé sur son principal
adversaire
adversaire 36 % contre 20 % pour hôtels
cruz il mène également dans les
éventuels caucus qui auront lieu en iowa
au mois de février avec 33% donc il a
beau être le meneur céline mais
plusieurs trouve que dans l'autre
chambre à dépasser une limite
aujourd'hui et qu'il a surtout mis en
danger le lien de confiance que temps
d'établir la police et au fbi et les
autorités en général avec la communauté
musulmane aux états unis et qui est un
lien essentiel pour déjouer des
attentats et identifier des éléments
radicaux qui ont pu s'infiltrer dans ces
communautés musulmanes qui sont répartis
partout aux états unis alors le mot qui
revient le plus souvent pour décrire les
déclarations aujourd'hui 2 dans le choc
c'est cadeau cadeaux qu'il a fait aux
terroristes